this redditor has landed on every single
planet and every single moon in
Starfield I can't even imagine how long
they shared a slideshow of some of their
favorite locations so I'm sharing them
with you via them this first one's
obviously just like a beautiful forest
with these kind of curved trees I
haven't seen those in the game
absolutely beautiful planet that's a
great shot sort of mars-esque Vista here
more beautiful photogenic rings I love
these shots I will never get over how
cool that looks this one kind of looks
like Earth if it were incorrect colors
and it had much closer moons love this
one how dramatic it looks like something
right out of Star Wars I love the
placement this person is like an actual
good photographer so yeah these are all
available uh widescreen on Reddit I've
left their username on the screen just
so you can't miss it somebody with a
super ultra wide monitor I might have to
make one of these my background